[Musique]
champion du monde de la pâtisserie en
2011 et je suis actuellement le chef
pâtissier de la maison Ladurée à Paris
donc voilà ça fait maintenant 20 ans que
je suis que j'officine dans le domaine
de la pâtisserie donc j'ai commencé
j'avais j'avais 19 ans et voilà j'ai
fait un apprentissage assez traditionnel
classique CAP BEP mention complémentaire
et brevet techniques des métiers
[Musique]
on a tous été jeune à un moment donné et
on a tous pu
compter sur des gens qui à un moment
donné nous ont aiguillé
dans le bon sens parce que les mauvais
chemins je pense qu'on en a tous un
moment donné
d'accessible et il faut les éviter il y
a toujours des enfin moi j'ai eu des
bonnes personnes qui m'ont qui m'ont
aidé à faire ces choix là c'est un petit
peu effectivement être présent pour les
jeunes je pourrai pas je suis à la
rentière disposition je ferai pas tous
leur parler je pourrai pas tous échanger
avec eux je sais pas exactement
comment dans quel état d'esprit chacun
partir enfin partir en d'ici mais en
tout cas voilà si on n'est pas là pour
eux à un moment donné faut pas se
plaindre derrière
[Musique]